christopher hitchens I just checked and
I've interviewed you 20 times since 1983
and I must say this is one of the
hardest well because you haven't been
well
nope very no what's the current status
of your cancer I have a tumor in my
esophagus which was some metastasized as
they spread to my lymph nodes and I'm
afraid they're not completely sure to
part of my lung and it's at stage 4 and
the the thing to note about stage 4 is
that there is no stage 5 so it
concentrates the mind a bit but I have
some wonderful oncologists working with
me
and there are we're on the verge of a
whole number of new treatments some
which may apply to me the chemotherapy
is holding it at bay I apologize that my
voices had been husky today but that's
the situation so I I have to practice
staying alive and preparing to deny at
the same time which as my memoir says is
actually what one has to do all the time
as much of fact I mean you're never more
than a breath away but it's a bit more
vivid to me you know sort of doctors in
the morning and lawyers in the afternoon
why didn't you decide to take us through
that journey in your writing in Vanity
Fair well I was wondering whether I
wanted to or not and to make an order to
make a parade of my condition but I was
very intelligently pressed to do it but
my editor Graydon Carter at Vanity Fair
and I tried to do it in such a way as it
wasn't the parade of my feelings Alaura
sort of yellow ribbon type journalism
and I've been told that some people have
been comforted by it a bit who
identified with it to some degree if you
have a lemon make lemonade would be the
other explanation better than staring at
the wall it is a great subject everyone
has to do this at one point or another
either survivor would die of something
like this that's one thing what is
certainly born to do so as an extension
of the memoir I published where I was
hit with it I thought well I should keep
up the narrative because this is very
much a part of my life how's your life
and I should add because of these
experimental treatments I've had my
genome sequenced for example I'm very
unique in this way I'm very lucky
I'm able to write about some really
quite exciting new developments in the
field of oncology which I hope will
surely become more available to more
people it's a rather tantalizing time to
have cancer it's exciting for me someone
of my age because there are treatments
that I can see that I just added my
reach probably which is both encouraging
and annoying if you like and there are
others that are probably just within it
my Constitution is very good all my
other vital signs are excellent
everything from my liver to my blood
pressure is excellent superb in fact
under served mine the case would say but
if I can hang on there are quite a few
experience I can and intend to try but
you just had your gallbladder out and
they had nothing to do with there
wouldn't no I had a very bad episode a
couple of weeks ago I crashed as my dog
sort of normally very admirably
diffident guy said I mean I had a
meltdown in my bone marrow that can
happen with chemotherapy I've had a
crisis with white hand blood cells at
the same time as my gall bladder went
rancid and I was in terrible pain for
had a burst appendix so I was really
flattered but I've now lost the
gallbladder and I've gained some blood
transfusion so I'm back hanging on right
question but what is this done to the
old head well the the worst of the
initial treatments was what's called
chemo brain in the trade where you feel
fogged in the head and you'd barely even
want to read little and right and that
terrified me very much because I thought
if I can't do that well I my raison
d'être in a way have gone in the literal
sense i I wouldn't
I have a very persuasive reason to live
and I didn't want to give in to despair
it turns out the chemo brain is
transitory I mean I still suffer from
terribly exhaustion I've got it now
physically but I'm I'm quite lucid at
least in my own opinion I could write a
column today if I was lucky I had some
strong coffee I can certainly read and
converse but if anything was to spread
in that direction I mean then I probably
would feel that was the end what has
been a reaction from other people to
your condition because you know a ton of
people yeah and I've also known to quite
a large number of people now and because
I had to cancel a book tour just as it
was beginning a rather lavish book tour
back in the summer I couldn't just do a
fade and go into treatment I had to make
a statement as if I was some kind of
public figure about why I couldn't keep
these appointments and people go into a
lot of trouble I had to say something so
it became overnight a sort of news item
I guess it must have been a slow week
and I imagine partly because of my
opinions about the supernatural in the
religious life I also got a lot of
attention because people thought well
surely now would be the time for me to
make a reconsideration withdraw from the
principles of a lifetime make my peace
with some church or other and it was a
lot of public talk about that there was
a day of prayer for me a National Day of
Prayer which I I took kindly I thought
it was at least a gesture of solidarity
but that was by the way prayer in my
favor the were other people who lobbied
the divine in the opposite direction
presuming to instruct him in either case
seems to me a bit presumptuous but
people can't seem to help that and I've
had an amazing number of letters from
people I still get them handwritten once
in the house as well as emails to my
office in New York saying really the
nicest things most of them not all and
trying to assure me that in their minds
my life hasn't been a waste of time even
if it ends premature
I'm 62 in April if I make it that far
and believe me that's been encouraging
I've learned something from it which is
some which ice of course like most of
the things one knows that are important
already known to me but now I really
know it now never put off writing a
letter to someone who's in distress well
it's always very much appreciated and
I'm not asking for more people to write
to me but if they have someone in mind
or someone known to them they haven't
quite got around to it yet I do urge
them to do it it's been a terrific help
to me I must say and I'm not
particularly what's the word vulnerable
person in that way not that easily
stirred but this has been very very
moving for me and very confirming has
any of your at least professional
enemies come to you during this time if
they have what would they say mean what
professional enemies so I suppose rivals
or people who take the opposite view not
all of them have been very nice and I've
had I mean you know newspaper columns
written about me in the New York Times
in them by David Brooks very generous
column and another one about Timothy
Egan in The Times it was an editorial in
The Times of London I began to feel as
if I was reading my bit reason but but
because I was still alive only the nice
bits would be in French Edison well and
I thought it's nice but of course it
gave me the slightly creepy feeling of
it being premature as well I don't know
how many personal enemies I have my
people just don't like me another
whistle one whose nerves I get but the
number of people who have written to me
saying they hope I suffer now and then
forever after I've tied is I'd say
heartening Li small you're back for them
a moment because it was quite a series
of events I mean I'm I have your memoir
in my hands and in which the first yes
and the first seven pages are all about
death did you have any premonition at
all no but it is weird isn't it
no I had a free gift from the National
Portrait Gallery
which publishes a a magazine for
subscribers about its upcoming
exhibitions and there was an exhibition
for the Friends of Martian Amos who the
friend of mine photographs which
included me and because one of the
people featured had died while the
catalog was going to press they put
hastily in the words the late but they
put next to my name so for the first
time my life I saw the words the late
Christopher Hitchens in print and it
does so ever used the expression
concentrate the night they wrote me
groveling I think they thought I was
going to sue and said they've all be
withdrawn will pulp them only a few got
out since alright and I said no no I
want you to send me as many as you've
got because it makes a wonderful mini
introduction to my memoir which I nearly
finished it so I wrote a it's called a
prologue with premonitions reminiscent
the reminiscence story a meditation on
death but at that stage I had no idea
who I was no none but you went on The
Daily Show with Jon Stewart right around
the time that you found out I went not
sure the day I was diagnosed you know
did you know it at the time yes I've
been told in the morning I've woken up
in New York feeling very ill and had to
be taken to hospital and they said I
thought I had was having a heart attack
this it's not your heart you can
discharge yourself if you want though we
recommend you stay in for observation
but whatever you do the next stop must
be with an oncologist that's clearly a
tumor we probably in your esophagus but
it's spread so I decided to discharge
myself because I wanted to do the
Stewart show and also that evening a big
event of the New York Way HCA the 92nd
Street Y circle big public that with
Salman Rushdie and I managed to do both
of these without showing any ill effects
but I just had the sentence read to me
yet actually as I saw you on the Jon
Stewart Show you look like you you had a
sense of humor Eeyore fairly normal what
was your head telling you when you were
walking out there well I
I just buried the thought for what it
took to do the show and then later this
onstage event with Salman which also
went very well it was only at the dinner
after that that I began to feel I
couldn't carry on anymore
but like I should get through it I
didn't anyone noticed but I was at every
opportunity between these events I was
violently sick threw up very powerfully
and you had any indication at all that
something was gone wrong no I had heard
nothing but very very good annual
checkup reports and my daughter's on all
fronts your father died of esophageal
can he did at the age of 79
it had that penetrated I mean it was it
it I mentioned it in the book I mean I
would have written that before I found
out myself but no I suppose because I
used to smoke very heavily I was afraid
of whistle getting it in the lung I
seemed to lead a charmed life but the
thing about esophageal cancer is you can
have it for quite a while it's very hard
to detect unless you have an upper GI
almost every month and you're looking
for it you very likely to miss in and it
doesn't usually present as they say till
it's metastasized by the time I went to
the doctor for a biopsy it was very easy
to do because you could feel it in the
lymph node on my neck which is not a
good sign you began what kind of
treatment I began a cisplatin it's cool
treatment of chemotherapy which made me
then lose all my hair it's growing back
with the new chemical I'm trying
slightly and maybe lose a lot of weight
and made me very tired but knocked it
back perceptibly I mean you could
it was measurably reduced and where did
you have this done in Bethesda and that
started what month last year July and it
ended when what's still going on still
going on yes I'm hoping now you see
because thanks to a wonderful American
doctor Francis Collins who's the head of
the National Institute of Health which
includes the National Cancer Institute
who did the
and Genome Project brought a gentleness
you know ahead of time and under budget
Marvis scientific achievement he and
I've met because we're opposite sides of
the religion debate we became friends
that way he's a very convinced Christian
and we become friendly debaters and he's
taking it very kindly interest in my
case and has helped me have my genome
sequenced and trying to look for a more
perfect identifiable match for any
mutation they can find this peculiar to
me that could be targeted by a special
drug so today is Friday the 14th I don't
know when this will be shown on Monday
I'm going in I hope to try that if I'm
strong enough if my bone marrow is
recovered enough and that involved 6
million no excuse me 6 billion DNA
matches of my tumor set against 6
billion DNA matches of my blood to look
for something that was individually
mutated that wasn't in my genes
absolutely extraordinary what can be
done now I had to go to st. Louis to do
it why st. Louis that seems to be where
the project is for finding out how the
genome can be applied to individuals
predicaments in medicine it'll be
commonplace soon there's a terrible lack
of funding as you perhaps know I might
just say what about this now so people
can write their congressmen in the most
recent budget are terrible collapsing
funding to the NIH and of course there's
this stupid attempt to limit the extent
which actually existing embryonic cells
can be used for this kind of thing and
I've become but I was anyway before this
but I would like to become more than I
am as an advocate for overcoming these
pseudo scientific obstacles to medical
research so where did you get you get
your chemo treatment at NIH no no I've
had various tests there but I just go to
my regular oncologist it's a very
brilliant man called dr. Smith in
Bethesda who's who consults over the
internet with
with like-minded experts and they work
out some caching and elsewhere they
working out a protocol for me and adjust
it every few weeks in in a Vanity Fair
December issue you wrote about a woman
who came up to you at a when you were
signing books yeah she starts off by
saying should I tell it if you can tell
I did it I've got it I've got it here in
case ya tell it well this is my campaign
to have a book of cancer etiquette
published which I might do signing books
in new after debate with tariq ramadhan
about Islam it's a long line woman at
the front comes towards me she doesn't
even have a book for me I wasn't bought
one says sorry here ill and I said well
it's very nice for you say so she said a
cousin of mine had cancer and I said I'm
really sorry you know and he said yes
and in the liver I said well that's true
for him I'm really that's awful
and she said but he got better I said
I'm good
and then she said but he got much worse
again and I said I'm sorry and he was
sitting of course he was a homosexual
and I thought I'm not gonna say of
course how was I supposed to know and
all his friends and family abandoned him
and he died alone and in great pain
agony incontinence piercing pain
humiliation indescribable horror and I
said well I I was beginning to run out
of things to say but I've expressed
consideration with that and then she
said so I just wanted you to know I know
exactly what you came I thought and then
left without having been by a book I
thought now would she have treated me
like that if I was well of course not
but people think they have they're all
mr. right if not a duty to do it if you
aren't said and I think we need patients
also need to suffer to reciprocate by
not sort of inflicting it on people I
actually have a badge and I'm not
wearing it a button that says don't ask
can I work Channel as some people do
make a huge parade if their their
condition I've tried to write about it
in other contexts example I wrote about
the National Day of Prayer and why
wasn't joining it efficient about
imaginative new gene based treatments
things like that I don't just want to
write my own tumor Diaries
that would be a little sort of system
but you wrote and now you're prologue of
your book as I sent a lot about deficit
which is cooled hich 22 I personally
want to do death in the active and not
the passive and to be there to look it
in the eye and be doing something when
it comes for me what what's that mean
anyway what is part of life so I'd like
to be conscious for it but this is what
I thought then and I ideally I'd like to
be making a speech perhaps or making
love or I don't know sitting with
friends or if I have more notice
conceivably to try a sort of Socratic
terminus where people gather around and
you try and make the fist of a decent
farewell I've have had cause to
reconsider that now because if this
cancer doesn't go into remission it's a
very unpleasant way to die
why well one quite probable way of doing
it is to choke in your own puke for
example not a very good thing and it can
be preceded by all kinds of imitations
so it's not that you're gonna die and it
was resigned or reconciled to that as
part of life it's that the sentence
includes that you'd be tortured for a
bit before you know and so I now feel a
slight bravado about what I wrote there
I would still if it were possible like
to be awake and looking at people and if
I'm lucky talking to them but I'm not so
sure I would insist on it
it might be as well to sort of slip away
you know in a narcotic
Stupa it might be but still there's
something about that may sound very
old-fashioned English say strikes me as
a bit ignoble as I say it's part of life
I want to I want to get as much out of
it as I can how much of during this
period of you talk about this kind of
thing with caribou your wife will a lot
because she's been a great prop and stay
for me she's she does things I don't
like to do going on the internet looking
up every conceivable ramification of
treatment and possibility tirelessly
looking for new doctors and new avenues
and things of that so we talk a lot
about it about losing about what would
happen when I've gone we've actually
barely have talked about that my
determination is that I'm I'm not going
to drive it well I'm not going to die of
it now I hope might die with it perhaps
some years from now that is a
possibility and I've certainly got to do
everything I can to be an experimental
subject for other treatments even if
they don't work for me I feel that would
be I say in the book I quit the great
American scholar Horace Mann who said
till you've done something for Humanity
you should be ashamed to die so it's
quite a high standard to reach well that
would be doing something for you money
and a fairly small cost to myself even
if it involved protracting treatment
unnecessarily I'd be willing to do it in
the middle of all this a couple of weeks
ago you debated Tony Blair yes
Toronto well I've carried on debating on
this and other questions but we have we
covered it and I don't want to run just
a clip of you making some points he's
sitting on the stage there with you
let's watch that and we'll come back and
ask your booklet as long as you don't
want your religion taught to my children
in school given a government subsidy
imposed on me by violence any of these
things you are fine by me I would prefer
I would prefer not even to know what it
is that you do in a church of yours I do
in fact if you force it on my attention
I will consider it a breach of that pact
have your own bloody Christmas do your
slot do your slaughtering if possible in
an abattoir and don't mutilate the
genitals of your children because then
I'm afraid it gets within the ambit of
law all right now so that's a judge you
think that's reasonable or elastic and
community area knows me I think it is
why is it a vain hope on my part why is
that has this pact ever been honored by
the other side of course not and it's a
mystery to me and I'll share it with you
if I believe that there was a savior
who'd been appointed or sent by our
prophet said porthos sent by God who
bore me in mind and loved me and wanted
the best for me I believe that and that
I possess the means of grace and the
hope of glory to phrase it like that I
think I don't know I think I might be
happy they say it's the way to happiness
why doesn't it make them happy
well generally it's a perfectly decent
question why doesn't it because they
won't be happy soon you believe it too
and why is that because that's what
their holy books tell them why did you
do that debate when was it actually it
was a Thanksgiving and what condition
were you in then well I I sub timed my
treatment so that it would come because
I had a lot of notice of the event
certainly would come at the end of the
tree where I'm much usually much
stronger because it would have been very
responsive it was a huge event a lot of
trouble money went into fixing it up and
getting Blair and getting security and
all this stuff so it wasn't what I never
looked like to cancel anyway but I
couldn't do that so I was feeling okay
very tired but physically alright and
mentally quite alert and it was the
first time Blair had had a public debate
since you stopped being Prime Minister
on any subject and then you wrote about
and raver yes and what was your take
from all that I mean you were you were
taking the position well you tell us
that your position his position I mean I
debate with the religious people all the
time mentioned teragrams and Rabbi
Shmuley all kinds of people I've debated
since I became sick Blair is of course a
new convert to Roman Catholicism so I
wanted to question a bit about that and
then one can only do one thing at a time
usually in these debates and the point I
wanted him to concede was that the evils
that people like myself speak about when
we talk about religion he will always
and his Co thinkers will always
acknowledge and they'll say this was
done in the name of religion and I said
no you must drop that there is
scriptural warrant and authority very
clearly in the holy books which are
supposed to be the Word of God for these
evils so it's a cop-out to use a
vulgarity so say it's in the name of its
you can't just say it's a parody of you
have to face the responsibility well in
fact when we were asked by one
questioner to say what had been the
strongest point made by the other he
said that he agreed that I was
right that the problem is that there is
scriptural authority for a great deal of
atrocity and cruelty and stupidity in
the holy books so that's my best memory
of the evening I suppose when I asked my
open with a long quotation from Cardinal
Newman whose beatification he'd just
recommended to the Pope and supported a
very wicked in my view quotation from
Newman's apologia and then I wanted to
know whether he thought the Pope was the
Vicar of Christ on earth where the
Catholic Church was the one true church
shootings it was quite strange he didn't
come up to the scratch to fight me on
that you could not have told him
anything he said that he was a Roman
Catholic at all he could have been a
very weak sort of Christian socialist
liberal who basically says that if
Christianity is okay because it makes
people do good works and give money to
charity which no one denies is true but
has nothing to do with the relevance or
the truth of the matter so but he's a
man with whom I sympathize in other ways
and I've known a little bit for quite a
long time so it was it was an unusually
interesting debate excuse me sorry bruh
just have a sip my medicine you and I've
I first interview I ever conducted with
you was on November the 7th 1983
remember it was the winter callin show
yes and I want to just run oh it's a
minute 24 seconds and then we'll talk
about this when when journalists lose
their credibility I think in this
country journalists have lost their
credibility based upon their past
performance the American people are
speaking out now and I just feel that
without no type of checks and balances
on the journalists they're doing exactly
what this gentleman's doing here is
bring the four news
over into the country okay report all
the faults okay but don't take a deep
enough look at the positive aspect of
what a Free Press really is I'm getting
fed up with this kind of questioning
actually I mean thirty miles from north
of Philadelphia as you are how do you
presume to know that the American people
are speaking out to the extent that you
do know or what is the extent that you
can speak for them you can only know it
through reading the reading of Free
Press and watching a free TV
the truth is that the papers are
reporting the fact that they're
unpopular with the administration and
the column with which David began Lou
cannons column today says he he admits
it's true that public opinion is
probably on Reagan's side on this one
but if you want your press to be treated
as the British treated their press in
the Falklands you're gonna end up not
knowing very much about what's going on
if that's what you want don't read the
papers but do not prevent me or anyone
else from reading them well you can see
how times have changed from that clip
there you were on our set smoking yes I
was doing that till quite late on I
forget wouldn't it stormed I can't
remember when we it's incredible now
when I see as one often does that shot
of water Cronkite announcing the
president's death in Dallas in 63 the
whole studio looks like Chernobyl so
ashtray is stretching as far as the eye
can see and I also appreciated you
calling me David on that show it kind of
was humbling what it's the name was then
the name with very distinguished Los
Angeles Times Africa correspondent ah
that was the reason anyway sorry all the
same I think it's very important to get
below that was it was it's fun to see
this for both of us go back to at that
time but but you know in those days you
were fairly there's a lot of bravado
about smoking and drinking and I for the
first book notes book we did I went with
you to a bar I remember and you had your
computer and a glass of something and a
cigarette you know I used to write my
columns in timbal explodey do you ever
think that this all this wouldn't have
happened without that and did your
father smoke is that where he my father
was a pipe smoker and a reasonably
consistent drinker - and I can't but
think that that's what contributed to it
we didn't learn much from his death my
brother and I because he was diagnosed
and died almost right away we didn't
find out much about I know it was lower
down than where mine is
and probably an operable then but it
wasn't a teaching moment by the way as
yours inoperable well it couldn't yes it
can't be cut out no it's spread cast
aside yeah it's spread it can't be cut
out and it's too near my lungs in my
heart to be properly radiated so it has
to be chemo and/or targeted gene therapy
but what over those years when you were
smoking so to answer your question of
course I always knew that there's a risk
in the bohemian lifestyle and I decided
to take it because whether it's an
illusion or not I don't think it is it
helped my concentration it stopped me
being bored stopped other people being
boring to some extent it would keep me
awake oh maybe more the evening to go on
longer to prolong the conversation to
enhance the moment if I was asked would
I do it again
the answer is probably yes I'd have quit
earlier possibly hoping to get away with
the whole thing easy for me to say of
course not very nice - my children -
yeah that sounds irresponsible if I say
yeah I'd do all that again to you but
the truth is it would be hypocritical of
me to say no I'd never touched the stuff
if I'd known because I did know everyone
knows and I decided all of life is a
wager I'm gonna wager on this bit and I
I can't make it come out any other way
it's strange I almost didn't even regret
it though I should because it's just
impossible for me to picture life
without wine and other things fueling
the company and and keeping me reading
and some traveling and energizing me it
worked for me really doing what over the
years is bored you you use that word
more than what's in your eyes well it's
a vice of course acts IDIA I think it's
actually one of the deadly sins
boredom what's the ante room to despair
its of the feeling that enemy that
nothing's interesting I'm too prone to
it I get easily tired of oh I don't know
committee meetings or not I have to do
many of those or waiting in line or a
very very impatient person so and I'm
very happy by myself I'm lucky in that
way if I've got enough to read and
something to write about and a bit of
alcohol for me to add an edge not to
dull it but it's been a formula during
this time of your illness have you
passed the time when and I have you had
a lot of pain during this time yes well
I especially before I found out it was
the gallbladder not the side effects I
was becoming worried that I was some
overdoing the painkillers I I got she
shouldn't be the other way around but I
said the doctors look I'm living I'm
dangerous removing from pill to pill I
surely shouldn't be taking this much
morphine or codeine base of stuff I just
need to feel woozy but I I'd like to
think that the gallbladder was the cause
of that because before then the pain
hadn't been all that occurred it was
quite deal able with quite manageable
you had became unbearable when we're
talking how many days ago did you have
your gallbladder 10 I think
Sejal 10 and did you have the
laparoscopic
yes it was all over very quickly once
they found it and do you feel better
because of it
not yet because the general anesthetic
takes a long time to to wear off at
least it has with me
given how weak I was already in how much
weight I've lost and how little food
I've been taking I couldn't have done
this yesterday for example really no
absolutely you know I could wholly get
out of bed about thirty some years ago
thirty-six years ago or seven years ago
a man named Stewart Alsop yes columnist
for Newsweek right I had leukemia the
AML acute difficult leukemia and wrote
about it I don't know did you have you
gone back and looked at any of his
columns no and he told the story he was
at NIH and and I think he might have had
bone marrow transplant remember for sure
but I remember I was glued to it and he
took us all the way through his process
how much more are we gonna hear from you
about your situation I hope a lot I mean
I did say that just for my own sake and
what kind of things are you thinking
about telling us about well I think the
main thing is to emphasize the the
extraordinary innovations in this condom
it's brought you medicine that are
becoming available based on our new
knowledge of our genetic makeup and so
insofar as these treatments are
applicable to me which they some of them
are I'm hoping to write in some detail
and alert people to possibilities that
they may not yet know about that exists
even for quite hard cases quite advanced
cases any thought of writing a book I
mean you mentioned earlier yes I thought
I'd write a book that was both about
facing death and about the struggle for
life and how one motivation for the
latter in my case apart from the obvious
ones is precisely to see if I can
participate in pushing those boundaries
back
enlarging the area of scientific
knowledge have you lost interest in
certain things in the world no not at
all and as you sit here today what would
it be your number one interest that
things going on in the world right now
right now well looking at today's paper
which is the first thing I do every day
still I suppose it would it would it
would have to be one version or another
of the confrontation with Islamic Jihad
in particular the appalling ly serious
news in Pakistan in the last few weeks
where the whole the whole threat seems
to me to be an amped-up noticeably in a
way we haven't quite internalized where
the Chief Minister of them our country's
most important state mr. Salman Taseer
his murdered in cold blood by some
pertaining to be his bodyguard on the
grounds that he poses an existing
blasphemy Lord not even that he's
committed blasphemy and so there anyone
claiming to be a Muslim is entitled to
kill him and that this got the
endorsement of all the religious
authorities all the mullahs and Imams in
Pakistan isn't so it used to be bad
enough on conviction by a court of the
charge of blasphemy you could face a
death sentence but she'd have been
through a jury an appeals process in
history bad enough in all conscience but
warranted by the Quran if you care tried
out but now permission to anybody to
appoint himself an executioner on the
spot and be the agent of the religion in
murdering anyone like this is
fantastically dangerous and we've
decided to invest ourselves completely
in the idea that there are moderates to
be found if we can pay them who will
fend this off I don't think there's a
prayer of that to coin a phrase
especially if we appear to be their
patrons how do you I mean I think we're
totally fooling ourselves
what about this process of having to
face this illness are you surprised
about and the reason I asked you about I
mean you went off on some substance
there and some people just give all that
up when they are faced with this kind of
situation I mean what what's changed
what what about this process surprised
you my internal process your process of
becoming ill and they tell you've got
Stage four yes esophageal cancer and all
that anybody are you surprised about any
of this the last six months
because you've obviously thought about
you wrote seven pages about death no yes
well I think a memoir of a person who
just passed sixty has to face that so I
thought I heard that much to the readers
no it hasn't been all that surprising
actually no it's a commonplace thing I
mean I don't
I wrote this somewhere I mean no I
didn't sit around asking myself why me
and if I did the cosmos wouldn't bother
to favor me with a reply I wouldn't even
say why not it's a commonplace thing the
son of my age in previous habits
it's almost laughably predictable the
only interesting thing about it is it's
possible Amin ability to treatments that
were unknown until very recently the the
outcome of brilliant work by devoted
people some of whom I'm very lucky to
count as friends you know there there
are many examples we hear from friends
and people we've known over the years
where a doctor will say some very
straightforward and crude things yes and
make life very uncomfortable I members
there was a reporter in this town worked
to Weston post he told me one day he's
no longer with us the doctor called him
after he'd had tests and he says guess
what you got the big seat and you think
me I couldn't believe that he actually
would you know that happened but
bring us up is that is a bit krasin
listen well what marks would you give
the medical profession and the way
they've treated you and now they give
you hope that this thing can be licked
they've given me more than a margin of
hope it can be licked yes and they
haven't pronounced on my chances unless
I've asked them which I decided not to
do at first until it occurred to me that
it would be very useful for if you like
the counting purposes to have a rough
idea because one has to plan for once
loved ones and descendants I thought so
for actuarial reasons I'd like to have a
guess they don't like being asked
because they don't really know and the
best answer I got was the following if
if you took a thousand people who were
myself in other words my age my state of
health my gender I think a thousand of
us today half of us would be dead veneer
of the remaining half others might hope
to live more than a year and of that
number question number two live for a
considerable number of years they can't
do better than that
that was from a very senior person at
the NIH who was expecting the question
what is your reaction to people like me
I mean we come to your apartment we want
to sit down and talk to you you know why
we're here we want to hear this story
and you've had a bunch here you know are
you surprised at that a little bit yes I
was but a lot of it I I know it has been
to do with my stance on religion I mean
very large number of people have asked
me doesn't it change your attitude to
the infinite the eternal the
supernatural and so forth and I I've
said that I really don't see why should
I've never thought of it as a
particularly searching question I mean
if I I spent a lot of my life deciding
that there isn't any redemption that
there's no salvation that there's no
afterlife
there's no supervising boss
- if I was to tell you well now I've got
a malignancy in my esophagus that
changes everything you would think I
hope that the main effect had been on my
IQ it's a complete logical non sequitur
that's nothing to do with it
so I've enjoyed taking part in that
argument and there's a certain ghoulish
element even about the nice people who
have been praying for me because they
all not just pray for my recovery
they're praying for my reconciliation
with religion and I I propose to trade
off yes sir tell you what what if we
secularists stop going to hospitals and
walking around the wards and asking if
people are religious when they're in
extremists and then the last days and
saying look you've still got a little
time why don't you live the last few
days of it as a free person you'll feel
much better all that nonsense they
taught you know you still you could
still have every chance to give it up
experience the life of a free-thinking
autonomous person don't live in fear
don't believe don't believe in mythology
they don't even welcome it and of course
we don't do that but it seems to be
considered the right of almost everybody
to do it the other way around I don't
resent it at all because I like every
opportunity for the argument but it a
lot of it has been to do with that I
don't flatter myself that as a public
figure I'm irate all that highly the
book notes show we did in 93 it's a
short clip I want to run this and get
your reaction to it but a lot of people
there the first love is what they'll
always remember for me it's so it's been
the first hate and I think that hatred
though it provides often rather junky
energy is a terrific way of getting in I
repaired in the morning keeping you
going it can be if you don't let it get
out of hand it can be catalyzed into
writing and in this country where people
like to be non-judgmental when they can
be which translates us on the whole
lenient there are an awful lot of bubble
reputations floating around that you
know one wouldn't be doing one's job if
one didn't it's to prick
so is it still a good idea to hate
people well since it's not really
avoidable I think the question is how to
if you like chanak's for advantage one
of the things I didn't like about
Christianity is the idea of compulsory
love we're saying it's bound to lead to
hypocracy people pretending to love more
than they do and also since it's coupled
with the injunction to love of God
you're also supposed to fear there's
every chance of that sort of curdling
there's something fairly honest by
contrast to finding someone completely
unbearable there's someone like Henry
Kissinger for example it's bad to let it
it's a bit like alcohol if you like it's
a it's a good servant but it's a bad
master I mean I have a completely cold
hatred and contempt for it but it
doesn't waste much of my time it's just
that it enables me to penetrate I think
the sort of fog of sentiment and bogus
reputation in which he's shrouded and
protected and it doesn't eat away at me
it doesn't keep me awake at night
doesn't poison me doesn't fill me with
bile but I can't pretend that it's just
a matter of political disagreement I
mean I think there is such a thing as
evil in the world and sometimes
personified and I think was under no
obligation to be ambivalent there Oh
change your mind at all about Mother
Teresa what would change my mind about
her I didn't never couldn't one couldn't
exactly hate her because in a way she
was a pathetic figure but I detested the
influence that she had I mean I can't
tell you why no sentence if you want
well the very reason that she's so
celebration deeply at this apparent
concern for the poor of the world or the
poorest of the poorest she was always
obliging us to say well as it happens we
know what the cure for poetry is a what
a certainty of poetry isn't it it goes
under the name the empowerment of women
it works everywhere Bangladesh Bolivia
name it give women some control over
their reproductive cycle
get them off the animal routine of
breeding
and the the level of poverty will will
decline Austria sharply it's never never
known two films consistent finding just
for an example this is my central point
about mother tree to spend her entire
life opposing the only thing that works
opposing all forms of birth control
comparing them to abortion which she
called murder
I mean directly in her Nobel Prize
speech said that was the main threat to
peace in the world was the fanatical
stupid thing to say
that's basically it that plus the
reputation for sanctity that she got for
preaching this nonsense but one could
add her friendship with the worst the
richest of the rich people like Charles
Keating of the savings and loan who was
a great friend of hers she took stolen
money from him refused to in the
courthouse true to return it took money
from the Duvalier dictatorship in Haiti
which treated the poor like pigs worse
blessed them in return gave them divine
sanction it goes on her whole effect it
was entirely retrograde and no one ever
wrote a but one story about her till I
wrote my critique and in that book was
very short I make five or six other
correct accusations against her backed
up with fat and that books been reviewed
by every newspaper in the world
including all the religious press no
one's ever pointed out a mistake in it
not one and if half of what I say is
true about her then none of what is
commonly believed about her is true but
I'm used to this now why people need
every nun then a complete illusion and
this was one what would you do if Henry
Kissinger decided to call you and try to
bury the hatchet after all these years
extremely interesting but one of the
reasons I detest him is I sort of know
that couldn't happen
he wouldn't even agree when I was
writing my book about him to have
questions submitted in writing let alone
to meet me
he's measured a condition when he
appears on television programs that he
not be asked about the book I know this
from the producers several of them he
made as a condition of his appearance at
the National Press Club which I don't
think should have agreed that he not be
asked about the book
never - at you to me there's no reason
to like me but I mean I would have
presented I was him I'd have pretended
who's this guy Hitchens i don't care but
i know i needled him but more important
if you think of the things he's been
found out as having done lying about
Vietnam mmm lying about Chile Bangladesh
East Timor the deaths of so many people
needlessly for the vanity of himself and
his criminal president we have other
people from that period in our history
Robert McNamara one of the Bundy
brothers others William Colby who in
their books and their memoirs tried to
make some kind of restitution listed
actually this was pretty bad policy we
sort of suspected at the time that it
was bad maybe worse and we're sort of
sorry and actually we have some evidence
we feel we should share with you some
disclosures that you should have had at
the time made some attempt kissing has
never said a word of self-criticism
normal one and he gets very petulant and
angry and spoiled and ugly when he's
criticized so the as chief says in
another context Bertie the contingency
sir is a remote one but if he was to try
it I'd be fascinated to meet him of
course we don't have much time and look
don't say that it I'll be the judge of
that if you knew that there was a
certain amount of time left I have no
idea
six months a year whatever mm-hmm of
things do you want to do and maybe gone
through that process yes but what they
don't tell you you see is what kind of
months these would be that's the other
reason they don't like being honest what
have you not done if I was in um you
probably remember stealing solos that
late congressman very very interesting
that have the same thing as me died
recently but he before he died he'd had
about four or five counts of three years
and you done a lot of traveling he kept
up his interest in human rights and the
international policy and then he got
word that it was back and probably that
that was it and he made fairly short
work of doing this was a few weeks ago
that's what I need to know I mean the
great loss to me and
a few months is the inability to travel
I got to Toronto for Thanksgiving that
wasn't that hard I've been to California
I've been to with a private plane
very kindly that was sent for me to do a
speaking engagement in Montana
I've finally got to see the Little
Bighorn which I've always wanted to and
the wonderful national part so I know he
got three American states unvisited
which one the Dakotas and Nebraska I've
done all this plus Puerto Rico any plan
to go back to your home country or
American citizen it's sentimental I know
but someone said to me randomly the
other day are you afraid you're not
singing then again and I realized yes I
was I I can't bear the idea of not going
back at least once but I couldn't do it
now I'd have to be told I was on what
they call a chemo holiday we are out of
time and I think the best way to end it
is to say I'll see in a couple years
absolutely this again you bet thank you
very much my pleasure
it is brightest
[Music]